نرصد الان من دير البلح مع مراسلنا هشام
زقوت مراسل الجزيره اخر التطورات القصف
الاسرائيلي المستمر والذي طال الوسط
تحديدا مخيم البريج ومخيم
النصيرات وبقيه
تطورات ما جرى في غزه في الساعات الاخيره
هشام زين في الساعه او الدقائق الاخيره
حتى الان قصفت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ثلاث منازل منزل منزلين في
مخيم النصيرات ومنزل في دير البلح وسط
القطاع منزلين في مخيم النصيرات ونقل عدد
من الشهداء والجرحى الى مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى المنزل الاول في شارع العشر وعائله
عقل في مخيم النصيرات المنزل الاخر في
مخيم اثنين وهناك عداد من الشهداء
والاصابات وتوجهت سيارات الاسعاف وسيارات
الدفاع المدني الى اماكن القصف الاسرائيلي
لا سما وان هناك ما زال بعض المفقودين في
هذه المنازل نحن نتحدث عن منازل المدنيه
فلسطينيه قصفتها الطائرات الحربيه كما هي
سياسه الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه الحرب
الاسرائيليه بدون اي سابق انذار ودمرت هذه
المنازل على رؤوس السكان في ظل ايضا
استمرار للقصف المدفعي على هذه المنازل
منذ صباح هذا اليوم ونحن نرصد عمليات
القصف الاسرائيلي سواء المدفعيه من
الزوارق الحربيه والان تتكثف الغارات
الاسرائيليه على هذه المناطق الوسطى ومنذ
بدا الجيش الاسرائيلي عمليه عمليته البريه
م منطلقا من مخيم البريج والغارات بادت
باتت تتكثف ومكثفه على هذه المخيمات
التابعه للاجئين الفلسطينيين ايضا في دير
البلح في منطقه حكر الجامع قصفت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه قبل قليل منزلا ايضا
وتوجهت سيارات الاسعاف الى هذا المكان
ونقلت عدد من الاصابات من محيط هذا المنزل
المستهدف لكن ما تزال عمليات البحث
والتمشيط جاريه من اجل انتشال بعض
الجثامين التي ما زالت في هذا المنزل
عندما نتحدث عن دير البلح نحن نتحدث عن
المنطقه التي قال الجيش الاسرائيلي لسكان
المنطقه الوسطى ان توجهوا اليها بعد ذلك
يتم قصف هذه المنازل التي باتت مكتظه
بالسكان مكتظه بالنازحين الفلسطينيين
وبالتالي هناك اعداد من الشهداء والجرحى
تكون كبيره ومرتفعه في كل منزل بالامس كان
هناك استهداف 15 شهيدا في منزل واحد بينما
هناك عشرات من الاصابات وايضا هناك عشرات
من المفقودين الذين لا تستطيع طواقم
الدفاع المدني انتشالهم بسبب ضعف
الامكانيات وايضا بسبب نقص الوقود
وبالتالي عدم تحرك الاليات الى هذه
الاماكن حتى الان منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
الاسرائيليه وهذا النقص في المعدات وايضا
في الوقود يعيق عمل طواقم الدفاع المدني
واي منزل يستهدف ويدمر بالكامل ياخذ دورا
وربما يمتد هذا الدور الان الى اسبوعين
وربما شهر حتى تستطيع طواقم الدفاع المدني
التوجه اليه وبالتالي انتشال ورفع هذا
الركام وانتشال الجثم القصف المدفعي هو
ايضا مستمر في ثلاث مناطق اساسيه هي
المناطق شرق مخيم البريج وشرق مخيم
المغازي وايضا شرق منطقه جحر الديك وايضا
المناطق الشماليه لمخيم النصيرات وهذا
المخيم المناطق الشماليه باتت تتعرض الى
قصف عنيف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه منطقه
المغرا مدينه الزهراء ارض المفتي هي
المناطق التي تتعرض الى قصف عنيف وفي كل
لحظه وفي كل حين تقصف المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه هذه المناطق بالقذائف ايضا
الزوارق الحربيه الاسرائيليه ما بين
الفينه والاخرى تكثف من قصفها للسواحل
الغربيه لمخيم النصيرات ودير البلح ومنطقه
الزوايده وما بين فتره واخرى ينقل اعداد
من الاصابات من جراء عمليات القصف
المختلفه الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وواضح
هشام ان هنالك الكثير من الاشتباكات
بالفعل في مخيم البريج وسط قطاع غزه اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا من دير البلح هشام زقوط وننوه
الى هذه الاخبار العاجله ايضا ك القسام
تقول استهدفنا اليه صهيونيه بقذيفه
الياسين 105 في مخيم البريج وسط قطاع غزه